[Música]
sí
m
y
cuando nos duele la cabeza o la barriga
que es lo primero que hacemos nos
dedicamos no nos asustamos puede ser
colocamos las manos en nuestro punto de
dolor que cree pues si ni bien nos duele
algo intuitivamente sin tener conciencia
alguna y llevamos nuestras manos a
nuestro punto de dolor como cuando eran
y éramos niños y nos lastimamos y le
decíamos a nuestra mamá mira mamá me
lastimé cuando nos duele en la cabeza
ahora en mi cabeza cuando nos duele la
barriga en mi barriga las mujeres cuando
estamos a punto de menstruar nos tocamos
incluso masaje amos nuestro bajo vientre
y me que les digo de las mujeres
embarazadas que se explotan y frotan la
pancita nuestro propio cuerpo nos enseña
a utilizar nuestras manos en momentos de
amor o de dolor desde que estamos en la
panza nuestra mamá nos está acariciando
una vez que salimos al mundo los brazos
son nuestros
una noche de fiebre y una palma sobre la
frente e inevitablemente nos sentimos
mejor
todo lo que vemos y tocamos a nuestro
alrededor y que podemos palpar las manos
lo han creado con la ayuda de la mente
por supuesto pero ellas van directo a la
acción ahí es que las manos tienen ese
algo yo soy sofi instructor y
practicante de yoga tengo mi estudio de
yoga aquí en la ciudad exacta cumbre de
la sierra bolivia en el momento en que
empecé a tocar a mis alumnos la práctica
entera dio un giro y hubo una gran
aceptación a qué me refiero cuando digo
tocar en el momento en que empecé a
ajustar a elongar a corregir la postura
de mis alumnos hubo una gran evolución
en sus cuerpos y una gran aceptación en
el ambiente mis manos rompieron el hielo
más allá del placer que se genera al
tener una mano presionando sobre la
columna y corrigiendo la postura porque
a quien no le gusta que le toquen la
espalda es cierto se siente súper rico
pero más allá de esto se genera una
confianza inexplicable una calidez una
zona de kom
y donde nace está mi fascinación por las
manos una vez al finalizar una clase una
alumna mía recostada en la posición
dejaba sana es la posición de descanso
acostado sobre el piso palmas hacia
arriba ojos bien cerrados pude sentir la
pesadez en su cabeza entonces
inevitablemente me lancé sobre ella y
empecé a masajear la porque lo hice por
mera intuición y qué es la intuición la
intuición es ese team acaso esa
sabiduría interna esa comprensión o
percepción inmediata de algo sin que
intervenga la razón entonces estaba allí
masajeando aquella cabeza pesada
cuando terminamos la clase ella espero
que todos se fueran se me acercó y me
dijo wow
sophie no sabes el dolor de cabeza que
sentía pero con tus masajitos se me fue
el dolor
y yo sentí que descubrir la pólvora así
que de a poquito empecé a masajear a
todos los mis alumnos sobre todo
aquellos días donde yo verdaderamente
sentía que tenía mucho para dar
incluso más adelante habían muchísimos
más halagos al masahito sobre la cabeza
a las manos sobre la espalda que a la
práctica de yoga en sí
un día decidí no tocar a nadie durante
una clase ni masajitos ni ajustes ni
correcciones ni nada y qué pasó cuando
terminamos un alumno muy tímidamente
dice sofía extrañe tus manos y el resto
acotó yo también
yo también yo también yo también a todos
nos gusta que nos toquen o al menos lo
hemos descubierto el gran valor de ello
pero por qué
porque tanto gusto con él más agito en
la sien y la mano sobre la espalda claro
que a todos nos gusta que los pasajes y
mis masajes son de lujo e incluso
pagamos por una sesión de masajes pero
la cosa va más allá es mucho más
profundo que solo un placer físico
me di cuenta que las manos son calmantes
naturales relajantes de dedos fluye
muchísima energía a través de las manos
yo con mis manos puedo transmitir amor
cariño confianza seguridad ellas tienen
vida propia cuando estamos nerviosos
empezamos a sudar si sentimos atracción
por nuestra pareja
queremos tocarlo acariciarlo la sazón
también viene con las manos una pizca
por aquí otra pizca por allá desde que
somos pequeñitos descubrimos el mundo
toqueteando lo todo y ya todos sabemos
que una buena noche romántica empieza
con el pacto nuestras manos son
transmisoras tele transportadoras de
amor en los dos minutos que yo estoy
masajeando a mi alumno porque juro que
no son más yo les estoy mandando muchos
relax buena onda les estoy regalando
esos minutitos de sentirse únicos
pertenecientes y el alumno se va como
nuevo hasta el día de hoy cuando
pregunto aquel alumno que no desea ser
tocado me lo deja saber nadie no me lo
deja saber porque nadie no desea ser
tocado
somos animales de contacto en la
universidad del reino unido jon moore
el profesor francis macklon habló acerca
un interesante y emocionante campo de
investigación la neurociencia del pacto
él dijo de que todos los animales
sociales y los humanos tenemos una
biblioteca de nervios que recubren
nuestra piel que responden al tacto
suave es decir él dijo de que las
caricias envían una señal a la parte del
cerebro que reacciona a lo emocional en
lugar de enviar una señal a la parte del
cerebro que reacciona a lo sensorial en
pocas palabras el dijo de que una
caricia un tacto suave induce una
reacción emocional
ellis experimentos tanto en ancianos
como en niños y demostró que aquellos
ancianos que empezaron a recibir más
caricias y tacto suaves empezaron a
comer más dormir mejor y más tendido por
las noches y lo mismo sucedió con los
niños empezaron a crecer más rápido a
crecer seguros de sí mismos y más
dispuestos al amor
ma clone también demostró que los
tiernos lametones de una mamá ratón a
sus bebés ratoncitos hacen que ellos
crezcan muchísimo más rápido ya que la
hormona de crecimiento se acelera y la
hormona del estrés disminuye y lo mismo
pasa con nuestra especie los bebés y tos
que reciben más caricias aumentan a
mayor ritmo su crecimiento y disminuyen
el estrés que aquellos bebés y tos que
nos reciben tantas caricias crecen a
menor ritmo vamos a hacer un pequeño
experimento vamos a agarrar nuestras
manos nos las limpiamos si las tenemos
jugadas y vamos a empezar a frotar
activar la energía vital y el calor
propio y acercamos a 10 centímetros
sobre nuestra cara
se debe sentir un pequeño hormigueo y un
calor entre las manos y el rostro vamos
otra vez
cortamos frotamos y acercamos
lo sienten
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio vamos a
activar aplaudir gracias gracias
aplaudimos aplaudimos y acercamos a las
orejas debemos de sentir una vibración
un hormigueo un calor
nuestras manos son súper poderosas si
tenemos superpoderes todos nosotros en
nuestras manos fluye un canal de energía
infinito seguro ya muchos lo saben pero
a medida que tenemos tantas
distracciones virtuales vamos perdiendo
esta conciencia humanística por así
decirlo nos vamos enfriando tendemos a
olvidar que con un simple apretón de
manos podemos bajar la atención de
alguien con un abrazo calmar el dolor o
los nervios con una empresa azar de
dedos transmitir al compañerismo la
lealtad el amor con un masajito en la
sien regalar un gran momento de cariño
de confianza tendemos a olvidarnos que
nuestras manos literal tenemos el poder
tenemos una herramienta súper poderosa
para nutrirnos día a día y crear
relaciones súper positivas a través del
tacto suave
los invito a tocar a experimentar más en
sus casas sus hogares con su familia sus
hijos sus amigos a crear lazos fuertes y
hermosos y super positivos a través del
tacto suave sobre todo en aquellos
momentos donde sentimos que no tienen
nada solución o estamos un poco tensos
tenemos una medicina natural en las
manos no la pasemos por alto
toquemos más toquemos más veamos como
una simple caricia nos logra conectar
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]